hemos hablado de que el propósito del
sistema linfático es recolectar el
fluido que ha sido exprimido de los
vasos sanguíneos como este para después
regresarlo a la sangre y así evitar que
se pierda demasiado fluido este es un
vaso sanguíneo rodeado de células que
quizá están siendo alimentadas por ese
vaso sanguíneo y al mismo tiempo tenemos
estos vasos linfáticos que pareciera que
surgen de la nada y son porosos de
manera que pueden recolectar el fluido
que fue exprimido fuera de los vasos
sanguíneos y finalmente regresar ese
fluido a la sangre pero el sistema
linfático también tiene otros propósitos
nos ayuda de otras formas y aquí vamos a
hablar de una de esas formas en las que
nos ayuda para hablar de esto tenemos
que hablar también acerca de las
infecciones una infección ocurre cuando
el cuerpo es atacado por un invasor
externo ese invasor usualmente es una
bacteria o un virus en este caso vamos a
hablar de una bacteria digamos que una
bacteria está infectando este tejido y
lo primero que se pueden preguntar
porque estoy dibujando las bacterias
aquí afuera del vaso sanguíneo quizás
debería dibujarlas en la sangre pero
porque se piensa esto
pensemos en cuando nos infecta mos por
ejemplo muchas veces al cortarnos la
herida se nos puede infectar y cuando
nos cortamos vemos sangre por lo que
podemos pensar que nos infecta mos
porque los virus o las bacterias están
entrando a la sangre pero eso no es del
todo cierto por lo general las
infecciones no se encuentran en la
sangre y hay una demostración sencilla
de esto ya que cuando nos infecta moss
las infecciones casi siempre son locales
es decir que casi siempre se quedan en
un lugar piensa en que cuando se les
infecta un corte por ejemplo en el dedo
la infección se queda en el dedo y
cuando tenemos una idea o una infección
en vías urinarias esa infección
normalmente se queda en el tracto
urinario o en una neumonía la infección
se queda en los pulmones si la infección
estuviera en la sangre llegaría a todo
el cuerpo lo que a veces ocurre pero eso
es algo mucho más serio que la mayoría
de las infecciones por
la forma más adecuada de dibujar una
infección típica es dibujar la infección
en los tejidos cuando tenemos esta
infección hay algunas células
inmunológicas locales que tiene el
cuerpo que van a combatir a estas
bacterias y van a tratar de matarlas
pero el cuerpo también tiene defensas
más fuertes que consisten en células ve
y en células de las cuales forman parte
del sistema inmunológico adaptativo lo
que significa que reaccionan ante este
invasor en específico a diferencia de
estas células de acá que en su mayor
parte son macrófagos y que pelean contra
muchos tipos diferentes de bacterias
estas células b&t van a reaccionar
contra esta bacteria específica teniendo
un efecto más poderoso contra ellas
debido a que se especializan en
determinado invasor el problema está en
que estas células no se encuentran por
aquí en los tejidos en donde comienza la
infección hay varias razones para esto
pero la más importante es que para que
estas células de híber se especialicen
en contra de estos invasores son
necesarios procesos complejos
no pueden ocurrir aquí afuera en los
tejidos se requiere de un medio ambiente
especial que estoy dibujando aquí que es
como un campo de entrenamiento en el que
se pueden desarrollar estas células para
responder a este tipo específico de
invasor pero ahora nos enfrentamos a un
problema porque como mencionamos antes
estas bacterias se quedan en este tejido
no son arrastradas por la sangre para
ser llevadas con las células t y ve por
aquí se quedan en el tejido y estas
células t y ve no están en estos tejidos
cómo podemos llevar estas células a
dónde están estas bacterias para que
puedan reaccionar contra ellas es
justamente lo que hace el sistema
linfático porque estas bacterias van a
ser absorbidas aquí y al mismo tiempo
estos macrófagos pueden tragarse algunas
de estas bacterias y una vez que lo han
hecho ellos podrían migrar a estos vasos
linfáticos resulta que la forma en la
que el cuerpo resuelve esto es llevar
todas estas cosas directamente al nódulo
linfático más cercano es así como se
llama esta estructura nódulo linfático
se llama nódulo porque es un órgano
pequeño
el cuerpo y tiene forma más o menos
circular la forma en la que la linfa se
relaciona con el hecho de que aquí haya
células b&t que también es algo muy
conveniente es debido a los vasos
linfáticos estas bacterias y algunos de
estos macrófagos que llevan bacterias
son barridos y llevados a las células 20
que ahora pueden especializarse y
multiplicarse para estar listas para
combatir esta infección aquí no vamos a
hablar sobre cómo hacen esto porque es
un tema para otro vídeo pero solo quiero
mencionar que como dijimos el propósito
principal del sistema linfático y estos
vasos linfáticos es llevar el fluido de
regreso a la sangre por lo que
obviamente para cuando todo esto llega
al nódulo linfático éste no puede ser el
fin del vaso linfático el vaso linfático
va a continuar y llevará el fluido de
regreso a la sangre otro efecto
secundario de tener estos nódulos
linfáticos aquí esparcidos por todos los
vasos linfáticos es que filtran todo
este fluido que va a regresar a la
sangre si no tuviéramos este nódulo
linfático aquí
aún necesitaríamos los vasos linfáticos
para regresar el fluido de vuelta a la
sangre y lo que sucedería es que estas
bacterias llegarían directamente al
flujo sanguíneo lo que sería un problema
porque como mencionamos antes las
infecciones en la sangre son mucho más
serias que las infecciones locales en
los tejidos este nódulo linfático se
comporta como un filtro para la linfa
que pasa por él de hecho también tiene
algunos macrófagos para ayudar a devorar
algunas de las bacterias que estén
pasando por aquí en resumen creo que lo
que tenemos es un sistema muy elegante
hemos desarrollado una manera de
arrastrar estas bacterias invasoras a
básicamente la estación de policía más
cercana y al mismo tiempo desarrollamos
un sistema que toma el fluido que es
exprimido de estos vasos sanguíneos y lo
filtra conforme pasa por aquí de manera
que para cuando llega al final este
fluido está libre de bacterias o de
cualquier otro residuo antes de terminar
hablemos un poco más acerca de estos
nódulos linfáticos y cómo son en
realidad por lo general son bastante
pequeños de fin
mucho más pequeños que el órgano
promedio por lo que no son considerados
órganos como tal miden de 1 a 25
milímetros y son tan pequeños que
podemos tener muchos de ellos dentro del
cuerpo tenemos unos 600 nódulos en el
cuerpo y algunos se encuentran cerca de
la piel por lo que podemos sentirlos
estos son los más grandes porque sería
difícil sentir los que miden un
milímetro veamos en donde se localizan
algunos de estos en el cuerpo humano
vamos a dibujar una figura aquí
los nódulos linfáticos se encuentran a
lo largo de los vasos linfáticos pero
debido a que hay 600 de ellos se
encuentran a lo largo de los vasos
linfáticos más grandes que ya han
consolidado a varios de los vasos
linfáticos más pequeños vamos a comenzar
con los lugares en donde podemos sentir
los nódulos linfáticos en nuestro cuerpo
podemos sentir los nódulos linfáticos
que se encuentran en la región de la
ingle entre las piernas y el abdomen y
sabemos que tenemos vasos linfáticos
grandes que se consolidan por acá
que se unen y suben por el cuerpo por
toda esta parte tenemos nódulos
linfáticos a lo largo de todo esto y por
lo general cuando el doctor nos revisan
va a sentir los nódulos linfáticos que
se encuentran por las clavículas o
también los que se encuentran en el
cuello o quizá aquellos que se
encuentran en el rostro o debajo de la
quijada todos estos se encuentran a lo
largo de vasos linfáticos que bajan y
los vasos linfáticos que están en los
brazos también tienen nódulos a lo largo
de ellos de esta manera tenemos 600
módulos linfáticos esparcidos por todo
nuestro cuerpo un hecho genial que
debemos recordar es que cualquier linfa
que venga de cualquier tejido en el
cuerpo va a pasar por al menos uno de
estos nódulos antes de llegar a la
sangre de manera que la linfa que se
encuentra en el dedo meñique los vasos
linfáticos la van a llevar hacia los
vasos linfáticos más grandes en donde
pasará por al menos un nódulo linfático
lo mismo ocurre con la linfa que está en
el estómago se recogerá transportará y
pasará por un nódulo linfático así
toda la linfa que regresa a la sangre es
filtrada